welcome to my talk scaling agile in your
organization with Spotify model my name
is Steven vaunts first it does let's
congratulate everyone's making it
through to the last session of NDC you
must be absolutely knackered and I am
okay so it's a little bit about me so I
work actually for two companies we used
to be one company at the end of the year
but we it's a start-up and we split it
into two companies because we had
different investment coming into both
companies so the reason why that's
relevant is I'm going to use our company
as an example where we try to apply and
adapt the Spotify model to our company
and I'm also an author for Pluralsight
so if anyone's Pluralsight subscribers
you can check out some of my courses on
there I've got nine on there and we
regular speaker as well so it's my
second time back here in Oslo which is
fantastic and I've done picked all the
other NDC's as well including Sydney
this year which will be looking forward
to so rough again difícil alien so we
can talk about problems with growth sort
of growth in the company a company
trying to scale your teams up then we
going to introduce the Spotify model and
what they did in their organization and
then I'm going to talk a bit more about
how we adapted it to our organization
because our type of business is
different to Spotify so therefore the
model doesn't fit precisely and then we
can finish off by talking a little bit
about organizational architecture versus
enterprise architecture first of all
that's just a really quick overview of
agile - so everyone's on the same page
so this is a screenshot from the agile
manifesto is everyone read this website
before or familiar with it yeah a few of
you so agile fundamentally comes down to
four values and that is in device
individuals and interactions over
processing tools so you know how we
interact and work with people is more
important than what fancy Kanban board
you're using working software over
comprehensive documentation so you know
what we all strive to do is deliver
working software so under agile you want
to deliver smaller pieces of working
software as fast as you can so you can
get feedback and that's more important
than having comprehensive waterfall
style documentation next one is customer
collaboration over contract negotiation
so it is all about the importance of
actually working with the people that
you're building software for and how you
collaborate with them
and the last one is being able to
respond to change so the best laid plans
written down always completely
inaccurate since you finish writing them
does things change and that should be
expected and embraced under the agile
manifesto
there's also 12 principles which go
along with those I'm not going to go
through each one of them but if you go
to the adult manifesto org websites you
can read the rest of the principles that
are there they basically just reiterate
the importance of working with people
interactions and delivering working
software quickly now the most common
agile methodologies use these days is
certainly all of them the most common
set up to you tend to see is a team we
use scrum as a project management
framework but they'll also probably
adopt some of the engineering practices
from extreme programming so that's
things like test-driven development and
continuous integration continuous
delivery and all that good stuff but
also what is quite common is Kanban
which is a kind of a different principle
- and scrum scrum is more an iteration
based model where you deliver working
software say every two or three weeks
whereas Kanban is more about continuous
flows you don't work in fixed situations
you're continuously delivering software
into production you can have a hybrid
say a plant called scrum ban which is
facing as a Kanban except you've reset
the board after every iteration and they
fill it with a new backlog such as a
very high-level introduction of some of
the agile things that we hopefully all
familiar with so now what I want to talk
about is problems with growth and I want
to talk a bit about how our company has
evolved and some of the problems that we
face which is why we've looked at
adopting other models so it's two
companies or we split down into two
companies the first one is called buying
butler and that is a buying concierge
service which helps people buy cars
online and the second one which is what
I'm going to focus on most is called
writing them which is an online
insurance claims management platform so
I'm not trying to sell you anything it's
not a sales pitch we sell our offerings
into large enterprises so I'm not trying
to sell you anything so as I said
writing them is an insurance claims
management platform we're trying to fix
the broken process of making a claim on
your motor vehicle predominately at the
moment so currently at the moment you
know if you crash your car
it's going to be written off in the UK
certainly at least it could take up to
2025 days to settle that claim and get
the money into your bank account because
it's a very painful manual process with
insurance companies so what we try to do
is take the entire thing online
it's a multi-tenant system that rebrands
for the insurance company and it has the
ability for the claim fans and the
claimant to both log on so their own
individual portals and interact with
each other to settle the claim and what
we found is that by developing this
software we've taken average claim
Hannegan times down from 25 days to
about two or three days in some cases
for straightforward claims it's three
hours so that's the product that we try
to build so we started this about a year
ago so I started at the company last May
and I was five of us and you know we had
a bunch of developers real people that
we knew effectively so we have people do
a specialist team web development
asp.net at the time they're people that
are more focused on the backend like
myself and we had someone who's an
expert on a database so we worked for
about two and a half months to build a
Minimum Viable Product to test our
theories about trying to fix these
insurance claims processes so we focus
on one small use case which is total
loss which is where if you crash your
car is beyond economic repair it's going
to be written off so and focus on that
one small area and we rapidly built a
prototype a working prototype which we
pilots equally to large insurance
companies in the UK and this was useful
I mean it is it's not the most
attractive looking piece of software but
it worked and it helped prove the theory
that we can actually bring those claim
hands in times down so with this
prototype birth average claim handed in
time of about a week and also learnt
loss a lessons from it so after that we
started working on what we classed the
real version one where we effectively in
the code that we had because it was a
very rough quickly put together a
prototype and we started rebuilding the
software using tools like reacts Redux
es6 nodejs Web API a lot of the other
things that we're all familiar with as
we've been doing this we've been taking
more investment into the company to help
us grow so no VC investment companies
has been finding out about what we're
doing
they're quite excited about it and
they've injected money into the company
which has given us the ability to grow
and take on more staff but what we found
is that
taking on more staff quickly can cause
lots of growing pains so what we want to
try and avoid is complete project chaos
so at the time we put the challenges we
were facing so the scrum team is getting
quite large so we had at one point we
had about nineteen people on one scrum
team because we're just working on the
first total loss module we still had a
divide between front-end and back-end
developers which made it difficult
working out some dependencies difficult
sometimes
our design team who's working on the UX
was very much a separate function
they're run as a completely separate
team because I'll put together very
quickly and also the seating plan in the
office was very skip by function so we
had to move from a smaller office into a
larger office we wanted to developers
and everyone to get productive as
quickly as possible so we just let them
sit where they want every time we tried
to move the entire company in under a
day but because of this parallel
development is proving difficult so we
want to build we've got about six
product modules we want to build into
the platform but doing it in parallel
was starting to look tricky so our
current structures and support hyper
growth
so there's five developers in my last
year we're 42 developers at the minute
with some current hires I've just made
and we projected to be about 80 by the
end of the year with in if we get the
series be round which we're looking for
probably double that next year so we're
going to be growing quite quickly so we
needed a solution that allow us to grow
because the way we're currently working
wasn't sustainable and wasn't scalable
so we started looking around and doing a
bit of research and you know we had
things like the scrum Nexus framework
which we could look at and then if
anyone saw Martin's talk on that earlier
this morning it's a very good talk
and it's kind of like the next evolution
of scrabble is an extension of scrum so
it's quite a prescriptive framework and
how it works and he got more big
corporate things like the scaled agile
framework which is very complex and very
complicated and we wasn't really that
keen on it or is there another method
he's owned other ways which we could try
and do this so whilst was doing our
research we came across some videos and
articles have been published by some
people at Spotify
so anyone familiar with who Spotify is
yeah anyone work Spotify good it could
be all good so it Spotify is a music
streaming company a very good one like
that I'm a customer have been a few
years and so you pay your monthly
subscription and you can essentially
stream or download to a device any music
you want to listen to so it's really
really really good products and they've
had a similar problem to us but a lot a
lot further back in time when they had
to scale their company very very quickly
so they put out a couple of videos which
quite interesting so if you can take
photos of any slides this one's a good
one to take photo off cuz I urge you to
watch the videos and it's where they
talk about their engineering culture at
the company this is kind of what gave us
the inspiration for how we wanted to
structure our company so I'm going to go
over what what's in these videos at a
high level for the science paper if you
want more detail I strongly urge you to
go watch these so they found like a
Sturgill practices are starting to get
in the way so it's 45 decided to make
them optional within their teams so
therefore they valued the or they
preferred the values of the agile
manifesto which we looked at earlier
over any particular framework like scrum
and in terms of their management and the
people that run the teams they wanted
people to be more like servant Lee this
is poster masters so a servant leader is
someone who's there to facilitate the
team remove any blockers and make sure
the team has everything they need to do
their job it's supposed to be supposed
to being someone who just stands there
giving them orders and telling them what
to do so the way the Spotify model works
is they break their teams down into a
series of abstractions and these
abstractions are tribes chapters and
guilds and then they abstract further
tribe into what called autonomous squads
on a tray some diagram to this in a
moment these are these individual squads
or teams are free to pick their own
processes and technologies at Spotify so
if one team wants to do scrum that's
fine they can do scrum if you have all
months to do extreme programming that's
fine they can do it if another one wants
to do Kanban that's fine or they can
make up something else completely as
long as it adheres to the general
principles and values in the a DRA
manifesto
so tribes are effectively product
groupings in their world so you might
have product groupings like search the
recommendations engine the playback
engine screaming engine and the social
media integration and invent each of
these tribes you have a series of squads
so they're individual teams and the
squad can be made up of anywhere from
five to eight people so it gives you
kind of a good template of what you need
to hire when you need to set up a new
team so the idea of a squad is that they
are completely autonomous in how they
work from each others they're kind of
like mini startups on their own and
because of this autonomy is actually
quite motivating for the teams because
it means it's very easy for them to make
decisions they haven't got you know the
rest of the enterprise to contend with
when we make decisions if these
decisions happen quickly but each squad
has to make sure their vision of what
they're doing aligns with a larger
company vision so that's how they sort
of keep themselves going in the right
direction so squads are self-organizing
so one pods are in their teams they can
organize themselves how they want people
can potentially move between squads as
well if I want to if it makes sense and
this gives things a good sense of
empowerment because they haven't got the
end of the normal rigid controls of a
company around them so when they're
deciding what to build you know say the
management says you know we need to
build feature X into the system large
part the management's job is to explain
why now always start with why why are we
building this is it going to bring us
more revenues you can make things more
efficient for the customer does it make
things more efficient for us as an
organization then what they'll do is I
will work with the teams to decide what
it is they're going to build but then
it's up to a team to decide how they're
going to build it so they have that
level of control and autonomy in how
they build things so each squad has come
out their own effective mission and
vision statements which is you know the
vision that they're trying to work
towards and I should align with the
overall product vision of the company
but any point the overarching company
values and missions can always override
what the mission is of the squad so if
they need to be sort of reset because
they're going the wrong way slightly
it's the company vision that overrides
the
these squads have complete end-to-end
responsibility for what they build so
that they don't just build a piece of
software no chuck it over the wall to
the infrastructure team and let them
deploy they have full end-to-end control
so they design the software they build
it they deploy it they support it so
it's kind of like a DevOps an entirety
within their team so they look after the
entire product that's within their their
bounds so squads all sit together so
there's a photo from them there so
they're all sitting together on from the
right over there but each squad also has
a breakout area they must absolutely
huge offices but they've all got
breakout area with some comfy seating
area lots of whiteboard space they can
have meetings and collaborate with each
other so although these squads are
loosely coupled because they're you know
individual small teams they are tightly
aligned so they're not in competition
with each other as squads they're there
to be good citizens to each other so
they do have to talk to each other and
collaborate because if you don't do that
then you just go back to having some
chaos on the team or in your company to
help do this then the squad will
regularly have each squad regularly have
meetings kind of like a scrum of scrums
or you have a nominated individual from
each team will meet up maybe once a week
twice a week or once a sprint some or
quite sure what their cadence is for
doing that
and the idea for that is to help promote
cross-pollination of ideas between teams
so if one team solves a particular
problem then the other squad doesn't
notion how to go and reinvent that
themselves actually be able to share
ideas to make this work then as we said
before the management needs to be more
liberal than all four entities so you
need management that work as servant
leaders who are there to remove any
blockers and impediments of the team
make sure they have everything they need
if any training and something they
should try and organize that for them if
there's any dependencies with other
departments they should try and remove
those dependencies for them as I said by
cross collaboration with the squads but
they can share standards patterns tools
and practices and they're there to
support each other and they do this with
effectively adopting an open internal
open source model so kind of like you
know an internal github I guess so if
any team designs a framework which could
be useful tutorial
it goes into their sort of shared repost
other teams can use it so hiring into a
company like Spotify you're working in a
team environment like this comfortable
fit is really important so when you're
hiring people you know it's not just the
skills you know their development skills
that matter and of course that's
important but it's not the only thing
that's important so you want to make
sure you bring in people that haven't
got egos you have mutual respect for
each other a good appraising other
developers asking for help when stuck
you know they shouldn't see being stuck
in their works taboo asking for help is
fine and encouraged and the ideal people
you want are people that like to learn
you know people like yourselves he come
to conferences like this you know watch
poolside videos read books go to user
groups etc so said squads can define
their own process and actually duplicate
slide that shouldn't be in there then
but squads are free to choose whatever
methodology they want to use bit scrum
or Kanban or anything else so the upper
abstraction we talked about was chapters
so that's what these yellow lines are
that going across horizontally a good
way of thinking of chapters is is kind
of like a people manager or a person
manager who leads across the teams and
the reason they do this is if say one
person wants to move from squad a to
squad B if they do that they maintain
the consistent line manager throughout
because you know you're supposed to
build up a good working relationship
with your manager they're there to help
you progress your career so by having
your line management split into what I
call chapters you just need you can see
you can keep that consistent
relationship if your manager enough
abstraction they have in editing saint
called guilds and what guilds are
they're cross-functional areas of
interest the way that works is you could
have a guild for say web development web
api is and back-end development machine
learning and people can subscribe to
those guilds whether it be a channel on
slack or a meet-up in the organization
and it's just a way for people to come
together and learn who have shared
interests and Spotify now they've got
sort of a particularly big size they've
run these things I think every quarter
called the unconference where each guild
has the ability to put on a small
conference within their organization
which people that are interested can go
along too it's a really cool idea
which of my company's a bit too small to
run conferences but we we do make good
use of the concepts of guilds my doing
things like guilt it helps to encourage
innovation from the team by having a
good culture of innovation a to a
product diversification product
differentiation and also hope to explore
new business opportunities because you
never know who on your team is going to
have that next killer idea which is
going to become a really successful
product or feature on your product it
also increases your competitive
advantage because if you've got a
healthy innovation culture and learning
culture in your organization and your
largest competitor hasn't and that can
give you a competitive advantage over
them because you can innovate and move
quicker and also it's motivating for
staff I mean I personally like work in
an environment where people enjoy
learning so we all learn together so
another good way of encouraging
innovation is doing things like
hackathons as you saying that Spotify
does a lot the thing that we've started
doing it at my company and hackathons
when we do them relate image em resent
it on the customer so you're trying to
solve a problem which is going to help
your end customer and it can be deeply
cross-functional so it's not just saying
that the developers do it involves
testers it can involve products owners
you want to try out say new ways of
defining stories or hackathons a good
way of doing that and it's very much
focused on the output and so generally
when you do a hackathon you don't you
wouldn't necessarily do it on your
existing code base you start from fresh
so you know filing you and then you
could build it from scratch and then
once you've done that you once you've
done that you you look at what you've
done in a kind of like a retrospective
or a demo then any of the good ideas to
be taken forward into the product if
necessary
so sent like Spotify is very based
around communities mean we look at the
names that have been use now we've got
tribes squads guilds the old vase or
community sounding names you know if you
imagine an island in the middle of the
ocean somewhere with the tribe on it not
so squads in there it's all based around
community because why they pick those
names so it's very community over formal
structures so it's not about having
large formal company hierarchies like
what you might traditionally have a
larger enterprise so to make all of this
work releasing your software should be
easy and the way that they do at Spotify
they make use of release trains has
anyone heard of the restrain concept
before so they had regular scheduled
releases that may go out into production
say you know once a week every two weeks
or whenever and if your features ready
it gets deployed but to do that they
make use of feature toggles and feature
switches because if your product or
feature isn't ready you don't want it to
go out into production being turned on
so I'm getting oh don't make much use
feature branches or deploy it off of
their main trunk line so to make this
sort of thing work then I'll see an
investment in test automation and
continuous delivery is very important
you need to have a good build
infrastructure and testing
infrastructure in place so that's things
like you know your more traditional unit
tests and integration tests but also
external automation tests so you know
things like selenium tests which test
your product running outside in any
restructure a team like this and we're
going to cover this a bit more later in
the talk but you need to move away from
having a big monolithic application and
when Spotify started doing this the
application was one big monolithic huge
desktop client application so they
actually had to spend quite a lot of
time refactoring the application and
breaking it down into more discreet
modules so the way they've done that is
Spotify is now effectively a chromium
browser with lots of components running
inside it it's important that you don't
have a big monolithic application when
you try and have multiple teams working
on the same product in parallel so to
start ripping up each other
so it's a spotify model a silver bullet
is it the answer to everything and the
answer is no not at all so when they
when they did this they didn't sit down
and think we're going to build this
massive you know this really cool
framework for structuring the team and
then publish it and everyone will adopt
it that wasn't their intention they were
doing what they had to do for their
company because I was pleased with it
happy with it they decided to sort of
let the world know what they'll do so
it's not a one size fits all and this is
why I want to talk about how they're
trying to apply it through a different
type of business on Spotify so we've had
to make some changes though to make this
sort of thing work you need very good
support from the very top of your
company so from the CEO CIO CTO everyone
downwards they have to fully buy into
being something like this because if
they don't and you're just not going to
get in you out of it and it will fail
but the key thing we want to remember
then is with the Spotify model we're
adopting the spirits of the model but
not necessarily the whole model so we're
trying to replicate the idea but not
necessarily replicate it exactly so if I
want to talk about sort of different
types of companies
so Spotify is a business to consumer
company so they sell to people like me
and you know consume average consumers
which means they've got much more
control over how they build and release
their products so they're in charge of
the product pipeline they can release
things when they want there is a company
like mine writing them it is a business
to business company so our customers are
large corporate insurance companies to
the entire dynamic of how you build and
release your products is completely
different so we can't just go release
and stuff when we like because we have
to grab these large insurance companies
to deal with your choice of common
problems anyone else ever have that
situation and you're on sale or working
large enterprises yeah it's a completely
different dynamic so our goal there was
to be able to scale the company safely
as we take on more investment without
taking chaos so we know we're going to
grow very quickly and we know that
that's hard to put one of the hardest
problems you have to face is growing
quickly so when we started doing this
then so we thought you know the Spotify
model looks good there's there's some
good ideas now that we're on to adopt so
we start first of all started off by
looking at and how happy and engaged our
employees are
and I came across this diagram I use
this all the time so again this is a
really good one to take a photo off
because knowledge if you have printouts
of this in the office the diagram is
taken from an article on the Harvard
Business Review websites but it is it's
such a useful tool so it's kind of like
Maslow's hierarchy of needs
so starting down the bottom we have you
know what do you have to have to have to
satisfy the employee so we've got things
like you know having a safe working
environment you want to go to work in a
safe environment where you can just get
on with your job and be productive so to
be satisfied you also need to have the
tools and training that you need now
real needs it's also do the job
know if for example you're free sharp is
going make you more productive but the
company's not willing to pay for it
are you going to be particularly
satisfied because you're nice can be
harder so can you get your job done
without excess bureaucracy so that's
another thing which leads to employee
satisfactions if you've got lots of
internal politics and bureaucracy at
your company you generally tend not to
be that satisfied I certainly don't also
to make employee satisfied are they
being paid and rewarded fairly oh and
it's quite an obvious one behave as a
company you need to pay at least market
rate or better so the people won't feel
they're being devalued and once and move
on
so next level up then is how to make
employees engaged so first part then is
are they part of an extraordinary team
so this sort of comes down to your
hiring practices the people you bring
into the company are you bringing in
people that are absolutely awesome and
are going to fit into the team well so
it's not just skills it's it's more like
the cultural sort of human side of it as
well yet do they carry any egos I've got
perfect example I was interviewing one
guy obviously I won't say his name and
but we didn't - in him and his technical
skills were absolutely amazing
he completely ace the interview in terms
of his technical skills he's very very
talented but throughout the interview he
was you know continually having a go at
his pieces company I mean when was and
probing him on particular scenarios
which might not have gone so well he was
very quick to blame other people and not
himself so because of that we thought
well is probably not gonna fit into the
company of that well just because this
attitude is portrayed in the interview
so even though these skills are
absolutely top-notch we
and those are the kind of sort of
difficult decisions you need to make
when you hire to build a good culture so
another thing to make the employees
engages is it an environment where they
can learn and grow every day so are you
doing new exciting interesting things or
you just doing typical old school crud
applications with low text box on the
screen and as an organization do you
offer so the tools they need to learn so
things like Pluralsight Linda Safari
Books always a promo site first comes
supposed to but you know anything like
that and also for them to be engaged now
do they feel that they're making an
impact you know is they they got meaning
in the work that they're doing so if
you're working on something that's you
know it's going to be Bend or is nothing
to be used very much that's not going to
make you very engaged is equal to the
work you're doing so if an employee to
be engaged I need to have a good sense
of value in the work they're doing then
the final one on top of that is you know
so you've got satisfied employees you've
got engaged employees but are they
inspired so inspired means you know are
they getting inspiration from their
company's mission so this isn't just you
know have they got meaning in the work
they're doing so they fully Buy in and
believe what the company is trying to do
so writing down we've tried to really be
transparent with our staff and really
you know get them engaged in the whole
mission of what we're trying to do you
know we're trying to reduce claim
handling time we're trying to make
people's lives better now when you
crashed your car it's very stressful if
you've got children you need a vehicle
don't you seniors get into school and
whatnot so people are going to be very
upset when they crash the car so we're
trying to make their lives better by
making our insurance companies better
and that's what our staff buy-in so they
buy into the whole overall vision of
what we're doing but also are they
inspired by the leaders in their company
I'd like to say mine say yes but I can't
speak for them but I'm hoping they will
be like I said if we go on to the actual
Spotify model itself and kind of how
we've adapted it so we we bought in
another concept called Islands because
now Islands drive squads why not
so because we could we split the company
into two because of a different
investment pipelines coming into the
company so we effectively called the
companies Island so we've got buying
butler
right in them now all of our teams work
across in each company worth quite a
mission statement a set of principles
and a set of values so setting these
values and principles upfront it's very
important for the team so for buying
Butler our mission was you know to
enable everyone to buy the confidence of
an expert and for writing them it's
simply customer manage claims and
following that we set a series of
principles these are the guiding
principles of the company so we've got
things like deliver for our customers
customer so that means we're trying to
make the claimants life better even
though our actual customers the
insurance company open communication and
transparency so we're very open without
tournament teams you know we let them
know what's going on with your
investment we let them know about
customers that we're talking to so we
have a good sense of what's coming up in
the future of the company so we don't
try and keep anything from them so they
make money they should be empowered but
with accountability so Robin to be
empowered to make decisions but I see we
have to deliver working software so
there has to be a level of
accountability that goes along with that
fail fast learn fast and iterate so when
we try out new ideas we want to know if
they're going to work as quickly as
possible if an idea isn't a great idea
that's fine but we'd rather get to that
decision sooner rather than later so we
can learn from it listen first then act
totus all the rounds of delivering
feedback to people so I've worked in
many organizations where people can be
quite blunt and give feedback which it
can hurt other people's feelings so we
try to have a culture if you know if
you're giving feedback or listen to
someone else's view just make sure you
listen first make good listening skills
and the last one is celebrate small wins
so if we deliver a module or we fix and
major bugs we like to celebrate that
with regard for team lunches we go out
for drinks it's a little small things
but it makes a big difference to a
company culture it's off the back of
that then we had the individual values
which we look for in the people that we
hire so these are things like people
that are selfless
you know they're happy to admit and
they've made a mistake and learn from it
people that have empathy and empathetic
people that have courage to make bold
decisions in the choices that they make
people that are curious you know curious
about technology they want to be there
we want to push boundaries in what we're
doing
we're currently doing a load of work
around machine learning so we're all
people to be curious about that and fun
to learn Trust so we have lots of
two-way trust between the development
teams and the rest of the company we
trust them to get the job done and they
trust us to be completely open
transparent with them so they know
exactly where the company's going and
then we have passion and you know on
purpose we passionately enjoy what they
do
honestly I'm being constructive given to
constructive feedback and having good
judgments in the front they do so that's
kind of where we started before we
started splitting the teams off for
define the mission the principles and
values make them public within the
company so everyone knows exactly what
it is we as a company expect someone
from our people so then we started
splitting down to the next level of
abstraction so we're trying to work out
the best way of doing it what we settled
on is we work in different insurance
verticals so that's how we split our
tribes out so we have a tribe which is
motor insurance one which is marine
insurance doesn't work like insuring
cargo containers house insurance and
health insurance so they're the main
tribes that we have set up in the
company and then each tribe can have a
series of squads Agnetha so as I said
before then so the project management
teams and the management define why
we're building something why this is
important you know they explain about
the business ideas behind it and then we
work with the teams to work out what
we're going to build and then the teams
are empowered to decide how they're
going to build it so like we Spotify our
teams are completely autonomous and how
they manage their work we treat each one
is kind of a separate it will start up
but the consistency we made a decision
that was different to Spotify so we
along with collaboration when the rest
of the team's decided to consistently
use scrum across each team and the
reason for this is a teams like these
and scrum and B because we have to do a
lot of compliance reports with insurance
companies and one of the things they
audit us on is our software development
methodologies and how we run internally
so it's actually much easier to have
scrum rolled out consistently in the
company
that's not necessarily valid for any
other company or if you have a company
but for us it made sense so just like
normal scrum each team for state daily
stand ups or squad rather has daily
stand-ups the squad has a product owner
on the scrum master who works in the
team so this year we're down now down
into a traditional scrum but every other
day we have nominated members from each
squad who will meet up and have like a
scrum of scrums meeting just so they can
communicate what each team's working on
any one time this is really good for
trying to solve cross team dependencies
as well
yes ad alignments between teams so the
next thing we added again in the whole
tribes and villages sign as a question
okay yeah we did them every other day
yeah well initially we did it every day
and it was it didn't really work so
we've moved to every other day if it
becomes it's too much information again
we'll might move it once a week so at
the moment we're on every other day this
needs to be we'll change it so this is
one of the main changes we made so we've
got this thing running across the top
good lookouts
you know every island has a tribe this
squads in it and they have lookouts to
protect them so really what our lookouts
are doing is protecting the teams for my
own insurance company customers and the
reason for that is so under the agile
manifesto it talks a lot about customer
collaboration you know so ideally if
you're working in an organization the
people you are building the software for
may be in the same company so it's very
easy to work with them but the insurance
companies we work with all over the
globe
so what I'll look out slide is is
effectively a series of outward facing
project managers and customer
relationship managers and their
responsibilities to go out visit these
companies gather any requirements that
they have because although it is our own
products each company intending that we
work with has their own sort of
requirements are unique bills is
building into the system there's lots of
custom configuration that you have to do
so what the look-outs responsibility for
is making sense of what the insurance
companies want to do and then working
with the internal
product manager to make sure
everything's prioritize and then it
eventually ends up in the correct
backlogs for the appropriate team but we
felt it important to have that level of
protection I guess between the internal
teams and the insurance companies
because these companies they're huge
enterprises know 50 hundred thousand
employees any development they do in
house is probably waterfall they're very
slow in how they work so we wanted to
protect the teams from that sort of
level of bureaucracy by just having this
extra layer in the middle yet so
traditionally that these covers use
waterfall internally so one thing that
has been quite challenging for us is you
know we're building our own products you
know we plan things into the backlog
that go through planning process so we
try and release things you know when
they're ready but that's not always easy
to do
so sometimes we've had to commit to
dates which I know a lot of agile teams
absolutely hate having deadlines imposed
on them but sometimes we have no choice
so generally when we try and do planning
we try and do left-to-right planning so
we go through the scrum planning
sessions of our teams you work out you
know what's going to be in each bin and
then you can do a rough estimation when
you think something's going to be
finished based on the team's velocity
but sometimes if we're working with the
insurance company then it does
particular set of features delivered by
a certain time you then have to do
right-to-left planning so we have this
date fixed we then have to work
backwards and work out how we're gonna
deliver it and the reason that happens
it's not ideal but there isn't it
happens is because there's normally
complex legal contract negotiations that
happen with these insurance companies so
to get these features out into
production and get them using them it
might have three-month lead-up time if
sort of legal bureaucracy and red tape
that has to happen so sometimes in some
situations but you have to plan it the
other way around
so it's not always a right-to-left
approach though and many do that under
specific customer demands but it is
saying that has sort of bitterness and
causes quite a few problems previously
but we try to keep the teams as agile as
we can where possible another concept
which we started rolling out is what the
squad up there called the cross-cutting
concerns team and this has been really
valuable to us so there's one each
project or every project you work on
there's always sets of functionality
which spans lots of teams and product
modules so we've set up a separate small
squad just to look after these sorts of
affairs so for example we've recently
started building servers for their
identity server so you can have
consistent identity across with our
product modules because it spans a
concern across all the teams you set up
a new team which focuses just on on
those cross-cutting concerns another
example of what they're working on is
content and content delivery so we need
to deliver all of our content in
multiple different languages so we're
working with some third-party content
management systems and our own internal
API so that if we say you know for this
particular tenants it needs to be in
German all the content comes back in the
correct language and again that's a
cross-cutting concern a piece of
functionality that all the teams will
need to use the other thing that's
really useful and having a team like
that is they're very good at doing proof
of concepts so for example we've got our
products which we can be building soon
which is a payments module so in the UK
certainly when the insurance company
pays out they still send you a physical
check to cache it to your bank which is
very slow so what we want to do is when
you reach a settlement on your claim we
want to transfer the money straight into
your bank account so it's very very
quick there's probably about five or six
different vendors we can use for that so
what the cross-cutting concerns team
will do is an evaluate each of the
vendors and do small proof of concepts
so when we actually form the payment
squad team a lot of these decisions have
already been made so they can just get
on with the job of building the products
as you mentioned before so teams will
need to be autonomous but you also need
to have a level of accountability in
there as well so the teams you know boss
they have a lot of freedom in how they
work and how to do their planning and
how they organize themselves we do have
to get stuff delivered as quickly as we
can we're a start-up we're running on
investment we need to get stuff build
quickly so that doesn't mean you need to
have a level of accountability in the
team as well so you know there has to be
some kind of repercussion if something
doesn't get done in time although
generally my teams are pretty good and
they're very good at delivery so one
thing I want to touch on then is
organizational architectures versus
enterprise architectures so everything
we've talked about so far in sort of
taking a team and basically splitting it
into a different set of abstractions
that is called an organizational
architecture and it really it's no
different to enterprise architecture you
know you have an idea for a product and
you split it down into different
abstractions and modules you know you
have this bit talking to this bit of the
queue it's kind of the same principle
it's an architecture in 1967 there's a
guy called Melvin Conway and who and he
said that any organization that designs
a system will produce a design whose
structure is a copy of the
organization's communication structure
and then Fred books in his mythical
man-month book sort of quoted this and
he called it Conway's law so as an
example if you had a room with four
programmers in there and you asked those
programmers to write a compiler that
publicly write a four-stage compiler
because it's a function of the way their
team is structured so when we look back
at how writing dem was initially
structured you know we had the
leadership team we had you know products
owners and product managers where
front-end developers back-end developers
a sequel guy and testers so what we
ended up with was a very typical nc8
architecture which which was quite a big
monolith but then we changed the
organizational architecture to be based
around tribes and squads which meant
that the existing architecture we bill
wouldn't work for us because if you have
multiple teams trying to work on this
system all at once they're just going to
trip each other up and this could be
tails
sort words and removes over it's a more
modular based architecture where each
product module is own separate set of
pages it's got its own API is its own
document stores and everything
communications and event sourcing CQRS
and aventurine across a message bus so
the key message area is that by
refactoring the company we've had to
refactor and change how to build the
software as well you should do one
without the other then you're going to
run into serious problems yep just said
that bits yes so if you do one you have
to do the other okay so if we summarize
some of the key findings and I've got
some sort key takeaways from this so the
model was popularized by Spotify but
they never intended it to be a universal
framework that's adopted by everyone so
things like scrum and scrum Nexus you
know they're very prescriptive frame
ways I have user manuals that you can
download and it's very you know
prescribes how you build it or how you
implement it that's not what Spotify
intended they did what was right for
them they were proud of it so they
published some videos and blog posts
about it and it's got quite popular and
caught on but they you know to the key
summary then so you have tribes in the
tribes you have small squads which could
be five to eight man teams chapters are
kind of cross-functional or cross team
leadership essentially so that if you do
move from one team to another you can
keep your consistent line manager then
we've got the guilds which are
cross-functional areas of interest and
learning but as I said if you try and
move out and think about this then the
culture that you put in place is a
central and very important so this is
saying that we use quite a lot of our
company to try and assess how we think
we're doing with the staff so we hold
staff every now and again to try and
give us honest feedback on where they
think they fit and then we try and map
it into where the organization is on
this chance so some key takeaways just
of being the whole course answer series
of simple bullet points so this model is
really good when you want to rapidly
increase your team so we're currently
running seven squads at the moment
some are smaller than the others but
we've got seventh-grade squads so if you
need to scale the team it's very it's
very good when I need to Beyonce the
payments team for example I know you
know roughly how many people I need to
to hire know roughly what sorts of
developers and staff I need and what
kind of skills they need so I can bring
these teams on very very quickly but the
Spotify model is not one size fits all
you need to adapt it to your work
environment that's why I wanted to show
you how my company's applied it compared
to how Spotify has done it because we
work in completely different industries
one's business-to-business one's
business-to-consumer so things have to
be different it's not as prescriptive as
scrum Nexus or scaled agile framework
although if you look closely at what
we've done because each of our teams
he's running scrum but we do actually
have a lot of similarities with the
scrum Nexus framework to do something
like this
it requires adoption from the top of the
organization so if you haven't got full
support from the leadership of your
company then you want to try and do
something like this and give it a run
into massive problems it has to be
universally agreed from the top of the
company that it's a good idea to do
comfortable fit is as important if not
more important than the skills when
you're hiring
so obviously skills are very important
people expense to do the job but how
they're going to fit some work with the
team is very important as well so small
focus squads create autonomy for a
greater sense of ownership so one thing
that my teams have all said is that now
they're working in much smaller teams as
much less information for them to
process which gives them a greater sense
of freedom and it gives them a good
sense of ownership so we use microsoft
visual studio team services to manage
all of our work each team has a
completely separate backlog which they
manage themselves when they go free
sprint planning now we can look at the
entire all of the backlogs together
holistic clicking for one - but contains
breaking all that information down into
smaller pieces of work is actually a lot
easier for them to work in model artisan
colleges are learning cultures the whole
idea behind the Guild's is that you're
encouraging your teams to learn and sort
of grow as a team
and also if you change your
organizational architecture you must
also address your system architecture so
you can't do one without the other
because you'll run into problems
satisfactory I wanted to talk about
today so thank you for coming along and
I have a blog Stephen horns calm and
I've got a contact button up there if
anyone wants to get in touch almost on
Twitter so we be good so engage with
people on Twitter and also run a or Co
run a user group
I'm from Darby in the center's the UK so
we run the Derby EE user group so if
anyone happens to be in Derby on the
last Thursday of the month you're
welcome to pop along so thank you very
much now we ended the conference you can
all go home and sleep thank you
you